i want to thank you all for joining me
and our fantastic speakers today today i
have kelly scaff with me
georgette is unable to join us live
today but has contributed to our
presentation and kelly will be
presenting on her behalf
kelly skeff is professor of medicine in
the department of medicine at stanford
and specializes in internal medicine
he is co-director of the stanford
faculty development center
and a former residency program director
and associate chair for education
kelly has trained over 400 faculty
development trainers
who have delivered teaching improvement
courses to over 30
000 medical teachers postdoctoral
scholars
and social work faculty from over 20
countries in north and south america
europe australia middle east and asia
and georgia stratos is a senior research
scholar
at the department of medicine at
stanford she is co-director
of the stanford faculty development
center for medical teachers alongside
kelly
georgette specializes in educational
psychology and developmental
sociolinguistics
she has also trained over 400 faculty
development trainers from around the
world
to deliver teaching improvement courses
in clinical teaching
end-of-life care geriatrics in primary
care
medical decision making preventative
medicine and
professionalism in contemporary practice
in addition she has presented teaching
improvement workshops to thousands of
teachers
around the world so thank you for being
here and i will now pass it over to
kelly i will do my best to convey our
discoveries and our insights that we
have together
discovered over the last four decades uh
as we contemplated what to do today
we have thought about our work during
the last uh
several decades and found that the
field of clinical teaching is so complex
that even our 14-hour course is a
synopsis of that field
and the synopsis of that field is also
contained in our new online course
but today we don't have 14 hours we have
30 or 40 minutes
and so what we decided to do was to
highlight
and to distill some of the key issues
that we try to convey in our larger
course
so that each of you could walk away with
something today that you could use in
your own teaching
but also give you some sense of what we
do as we go into this very complex topic
in greater detail
now why did we come here why are we here
what we've discovered in our work is
that clinical teachers
are faced with many many challenges
here's a picture of one clinical teacher
in the center of this stage
and he's working with a medical student
who's presenting a case the supervising
intern of that medical student
the supervising resident of that team
who is there in the center somewhat
as you can tell a bit tired from his
on-call night
another medical student says standing
dutifully listening to his colleague
and behind them a day float resident uh
this resident is responsible for the
patience and the patient care
that goes on when this team goes home
so this particular faculty physician
is responsible not only for thinking
about what is it
that i have to consider in the care of
the patient
but what do i have to consider about the
care of the patient
that i want to make sure that this group
learns
this group in a one-room schoolhouse
which has
multiple levels represented multiple
levels of experience multiple levels of
knowledge
a setting that's not perfect for
teaching but has some
benefits and some drawbacks and also a
content area that is extremely complex
in the field of clinical teaching all
the teachers have to consider
what knowledge they wish to convey what
skills they wish to help the learners
obtain and what attitudes what
professional
values do they hope gets conveyed and
absorbed and embodied and how these
particular trainees in medicine
become the professionals that they hope
to be
so in that complex set of challenges
we have tried to look and say is there a
way to make sense of this
how can you look at this complex area
where you're thinking about content and
setting
and learners and concepts
and how can you bring it to bear to
where you can think about it and
understand it
in a more organized and systematic way
and so that led us to work on a
conceptual framework for reflecting on
teaching
and that's the framework that forms the
underpins the
entire basis for our work our course and
which
i will touch on today so that you get
some sense of that
interest from some sense of the concepts
and some sense of a checklist of a
conceptual framework
that you can use as you think about your
own teaching
during this webinar we hope that you
will gain several things
we hope that you will gain familiarity
with this framework so that you can use
it to analyze and reflect on your own
teaching
using this common language of the
framework
that you can examine and break down your
own teaching in a structured and
comprehensive fashion
so that you will feel after you've
applied this framework to your teaching
that you have looked at most if not all
of the major areas in teaching
and have at least considered and
reflected on them
and also it helps you both recognize
what you see
and classify what you see but also
by working through the framework you may
discover what you did not initially see
so that you can both recognize what you
see and what you do not see
in teaching interactions
now the agenda we're going to use today
is going to be made up mainly
of an introduction to the stanford
faculty development center's framework
for analyzing teaching
but toward the end we will also touch on
the background of our work
that has led to the online teaching
improvement course that is being offered
well here is the framework a list of
seven categories
seven categories that we've seen can be
applied
in any setting in any time with any
group of learners
across topics and what we will do over
the next 20 or 30 minutes
is work through that framework with the
definitions of each particular component
each particular category and we'll
highlight
just a few of the examples of the
relevance of each of the categories in
that framework
for clinical teachers we'll highlight
what we have learned from our experience
with hundreds of course participants
as they've shared with us the challenges
of clinical teaching
and the discoveries that they have made
by applying this framework
so let's begin
the first category in the framework is
the learning climate
creating a climate creating a place
that the teacher wants to have that will
have
learners want to be in that place the
formal definition as you see here
is that the toner atmosphere that
represents the toner atmosphere
of the teaching setting is it
stimulating
and is it a place where learners can
comfortably identify and address their
limitations
now why are we focusing on this because
in medicine
the limitation of a learner is crucial
to the ultimate capability of that
person to practice
and if we've created a scene a place a
scenario
in which one is uncomfortable to
identify and admit one's limitation
those may be hidden and is this a
problem throughout one's career yes
as we've learned from risk management
experts
that sometimes even fully trained
physicians
have difficulty addressing and admitting
their limitations
so the informal definition of this
category we would highlight is
have we created a place where learners
want to be
we ask ourselves the question would a
learner want to be here
and would a teacher want to be here is
this a collaborative environment
where the teacher is excited about being
there every day
or is it an adversarial environment
which makes it hard
for people to want to be there
now why is this so relevant to clinical
teaching as i mentioned before
admitting our own limitations is
challenging both for learners and
teachers
the concept of saying one one doesn't
know
carries such a weight as one has gone
through the entire educational system
and yet it's crucial for physician
training with
implications for patient care and
implications for the stepping stone for
lifelong learning
the admission of limitations being a
stepping stone
that one can use to continue to guide
oneself
as you learn throughout a career so we
highlight for you
that this particular point that
admitting limitations
is a challenging area is one that we
want you to have in your mind
as you try to create the learning
climate in your teaching setting
the second category is the category of
control of the session
now i would highlight in introducing
this category that the first two
categories
the learning climate and the control
session are unique
among the seven these two categories
are ever present at any one moment in a
teaching session
both the learning climate and the
control of session
are categories that are present
why because as you see in this formal
definition
this category the control session deals
with the manner in which the teaching
interaction is focused in pace
and the leadership style that a teacher
will use
those particular issues are going on
all the time a teacher can be thinking
about their focus and their pace and
who's leading the session
and the informal definition here has to
say has to deal with
how well is this session managed we know
there are so many things to accomplish
when we're
active as a clinical teacher and we may
choose
in deciding who's in charge where does
the teacher work
who is in charge of that session
now the relevance of this to clinical
teaching is that clinical teachers
may choose to use many different
leadership styles
we cover three in our course a directive
style
in which the teacher makes the decisions
about what's to be covered how long it
will take
who's to be doing what within a teaching
session
a democratic teaching leadership style
in which the teacher
collaborates with the learners and
together make decisions about how the
session will be run
and a non-directive teaching style
coming from the work of carl rogers
where the teacher really lets the
session run itself
and observes what's going on in the
session now what we've noticed
is that participants who've taken our
course recognize that they have a
preference often
to use one or another style and what
have we learned
that many particular teachers in
clinical teaching have been taught to
use a directive style
where they are in charge they are the
responsible person
and indeed from a medical clinical point
of view
the teacher is the responsible person
but in setting up the teaching session
they can be used then all three of these
styles can be used
a directive a democratic and a
non-directive
and so what we've learned is by teachers
reflecting on what are the goals of
their session
that they may realize benefits from
using alternative leadership styles
that those alternative styles will
optimize opportunities for them to
evaluate learners
in different stages of development and
also provide learners
opportunities to develop their own
leadership abilities
a critical thing in professional
training
this leads us to the third category the
communication of educational goals
what does this deal with this deals with
the teachers
taking advantage of the opportunity to
establish
and explicitly express the teachers
and the learners expectations for the
learners
we'd like to emphasize the preposition
for
because this category addresses how does
the teacher decide
what they hope for their learners
it's not only what they hope of their
learners what they expect for them to do
but what they expect for them to be able
to do
capable of doing at the end of a
teaching session
and it answers the informal question why
are the learners and the teachers there
why are we here what do we hope comes
out of this session
for our learners a very important area
something that has been in the forefront
of education research since then the
1950s the middle of the last century
now why the why are the communication of
why is the communication of goals
important
well because it enables us to accomplish
three functions
by being explicit about our goals it
lets those that we teach
know what to master it also may inform
you and me as a teacher
on how to plan our instructional process
and it provides us both the learners and
the teachers
with the basis for assessment
but what have we learned that despite
the educational value
of communicating our goals as we watched
clinical teachers we rarely observed
teachers overtly expressing those goals
interestingly enough there was a
an assumption an assumption that
everybody knew
the reason why they were there and often
that was at a very high level
that they were there to take care of
patients
but not at a specific level of what was
the
topic what was the ski what were the
skills what were the attitudes
to be mastered what were the hopes of
those teachers and those learners
for themselves and for their colleagues
so with reflection teachers can see the
benefits of communicating goals
especially when learners are not
performing at a desired level
being explicit about the goals the hopes
of what you hope they will master
and learners who are unclear about
expectations i personally have had the
experience
where i in the midst of a teaching
session would realize
that the learner that my trainees and i
were on different pages
because they were on trying to
accomplish a different thing
for themselves for their day than i was
hoping
for to help them gain and so there was
lack of clarity about the expectation so
we've learned that this can be
a very useful not simple but a very
useful exercise
to begin to define the specific goals
that we hope for the learners and the
activities that they will go through
to master those goals
and it leads us now to the fourth
category
this very large category that often
encompasses
entire teaching courses the category of
how does a teacher promote
the understanding and retention of
material
to be gained what do you and i do
as we try to help other people master
material
the formal definition deals with the
approaches that a teacher can use
both to explain the content that we're
hoping people master
how are we as explainers and also
to have the learner meaningfully be
engaged and interact with the content
assisting the learner to understand and
retain it
that it's not enough to have the teacher
not only be
a great explainer a clear explainer
but rather to also be someone who
orchestrates an opportunity
for the learner to meaningfully engage
with the content
so that they can have a true
understanding and retention of that
material
so the informal definition asks the
question what techniques
did a teacher use to help the learners
learn the material and again this
material is material about knowledge
acquisition material about skill
acquisition
and content about attitude or value
now why do we spend time on this because
of the frailty of the human mind
the human memory is a wonderful
thing when it works but here
from 1885 the curve of forgetting was
defined
that you and i as we learned something
have a long
and quick decay of our memory of that
knowledge
that this goes away and unfortunately
the mind has not
progressed so much so great in the last
over 150 years to where we don't forget
things
we still forget things so our chan our
task as a teacher
is how do we counter this how do we
enhance
the capability of remembering well
i'm going to touch on now four different
areas
that are relevant to clinical teaching
that have been discovered by our
participants
and have seemed to be useful now there
are many more that are covered in our
course and obviously
there are many phd theses written about
each of these topics
but for example as we hope to organize
content to where it is effectively
understood by the learner
we might use overviews sounds simplistic
but crucial you might imagine what
happens when you
walk into a session in a lecture that
you're a little late
and suddenly you see a slide that shows
the overview of what's being covered
and you take a breath in to say i know
where we are
i understand the organization of the
content
and we might as teachers recognize the
challenge of defining new terms
to enhance clarity that as we work in
our fields
teams which were terms which were
sometimes
vague to us in the beginning are now
commonplace
and we may or may not think about
defining new terms
a very useful activity we might want to
use
drama to emphasize the key content
that it is appropriate and okay to
recognize
that teaching is a performance a
performance with a very legitimate and
important goal to help people learn
about their profession so being dramatic
to make things stick to emphasize can be
useful
and the last point is that engaging the
learners
in the content they help them to master
it
by reformulating it so that we
feel the recognition which many of us
and i certainly have failed in this
in my own teaching sometimes that if i
think too much about what i'm doing
but not how am i going to engage the
learner
into a process that allows them to
reformulate and better understand the
content
i may miss the boat i may
use all of these techniques in the first
three but not
really successfully getting the material
to be mastered by the learner
because i haven't actively engaged them
we now move to our fifth category
a category laden with emotion
evaluation as each of us think about
being evaluated ourselves
and evaluating others we often have an
emotional response
is somebody going to judge me is this
going to actually
be a performance of mine that is not
positive
and in fact will affect my entire career
a medical student who's presenting
may have that fear that if his
performance is not evaluated well
his entire residency program application
gets
affected his ladders get affected her
letters get affected
if somebody's judging us so this
emotional area
of the evaluation of the learners
has an impact on how we check on whether
things are learned
if we look at the formal definition it
simply states
that this is the process by which the
teacher assesses
the learner's knowledge the learner's
skills the learner's attitudes
based on criteria related to educational
goals
well indeed if we have our goals for the
learner
it would seem incumbent upon us to check
with the process on whether we had
accomplished our goals
and yet this is so laden with fear
for so many people that it's often not
done
adequately the informal definition asks
the question
does the teacher know where the learners
are
and indeed as i've highlighted for you
this is extremely relevant to clinical
teaching
because we've learned teachers are
commonly
extremely kind and there's fear built
into this
phenomenon that the teacher is hesitant
to put the learner on the spot that the
teacher
is hesitant to make somebody feel
uncomfortable
that the learner is fearful of being
evaluated and not successful
we were in the midst of a seminar
recently in which
a senior resident
in the surgical rotation could have been
any rotation
commented that it was only in his
final two or three weeks of his training
did he lose the fear
of what he was going to say on rounds
that he lost the fear of being judged
inappropriately because in medicine
the concept of one being evaluated by
others
is a concept that is crucial to us
learning from each other
and yet evaluation can be left out this
critical process
for understanding the learner's needs so
we highlight and try to encourage people
to think about evaluation as a positive
exercise
now the place where the learner and the
teacher both can learn about where the
learner is
and move forward in that process
well it leads us to the category number
six
another emotional category the category
of
feedback providing feedback to the
learners
about their performance and we see the
formal definition
the process by which the teacher
provides learners
with information about their performance
for the purposes of improving their
performance
we often suggest that people think about
this put it on their wall
because giving feedback has this
wonderful purpose
of helping people grow helping people
get better
and yes it answers the question in the
informal definition
is do learners know what the teacher
thinks of their performance
as the teacher shared his or her
observation
in a way to where the learner
understands the uh
perception of others
well why is this a topic
of importance that we are asked to
commonly present
because it's very difficult
telling somebody else about what they're
doing well
even or what they're doing not so well
where they could get better
is a difficult challenge and yet in
teaching
and in the teaching of a professional
this is crucial
that a person learns what they're doing
well and what they're not doing well
from a perspective of another observer
who has more experience
and maybe more knowledge or at least
different knowledge
but sometimes teachers feel that giving
feedback
is uncomfortable and even
confrontational or adversarial
and so that is a task that they often
avoid
and we just gave a seminar a week ago
where one of the teachers said you know
we're always wanting to be
kind and nice and therefore we avoid
telling people what we're saying not
recognizing
that the gift of feedback of a teacher
letting a learner know how they can
improve
it's a gift whenever it comes with the
caring
of the teacher and so there is a
evidence to give feedback
and we've seen by many by many teachers
especially corrective feedback and many
people change the word
negative to corrective feedback and
positive to reinforcing feedback to give
them more courage
to do this our course participants have
found it helpful
to capitalize on prior uh categories
that i have already covered this morning
and they're envisioning the effective
feedback envisioning effective feedback
as resting on a three-legged stool
and here is that three-legged stool
that if one supports the provision of
feedback
with three other categories which i've
already covered
with creating a positive learning
climate in which the learner
knows about how much the teacher cares
about them
in which learners respected and can feel
comfortable
admitting their limitations in which the
learners
see that the purpose of being there
is for the teacher and the learner to
gain together
and the category of communication of
goals where the clarity of what
the goals are that the teacher hopes the
learner will accomplish
is made straightforwardly so that the
feedback
is in relationship to a goal and better
understood by a learner
where the feedback sometimes actually
comes
out of left field out of a out of some
place that the learner is not aware of
so communicating the goals can enable
the effectiveness of feedback
and the third leg of the stool is
adequate evaluation
of the learner by the teacher sometimes
teachers have to give feedback about
observations made by
others and so the learner may doubt
the validity of those observations so
having the teachers who make the
observation do the adequate evaluation
be involved in the feedback process can
enable the learners
to more effectively gain from this
knowledge
these observations by other teachers
it leads us now to the last category
the category which we call promoting
self-directed learning
this category is somewhat different than
the other six
the learner is crucial in all seven
categories
but this category promoting
self-directed learning
takes advantage of the
inherent drive and motivation
that each human has it takes advantage
of the individual learners needs the
individual learners goals the individual
learners interest
so this category deals with approaches
that you and i as a teacher can use
to take that motivation
and to influence that motivation to
bring it out
into the teaching setting and to use
that motivation
to capitalize on the use of resources
a technique to fostering self-directed
learning
so we asked the question in this
category is the learning that's being
done by the clinical teacher
being driven by the learners motivation
by the learner's needs by the learner's
goals
by the learner's interest and many of us
because medicine is such a big topic
may have clearly defined what we believe
somebody else should know and not taken
advantage of this
incredible powerful force inside of
every human being
to continue to learn
now why is the challenge and why do we
want to spend time on this
because it's possible that self-directed
learning
learning driven by the learner's own
desires goals and interests
may be suppressed that when the workload
gets too high
the desire for me to learn about even
things that i'm interested in
when the content volume of what the
teacher has to cover
may be so big that i may forget that i
really came
to this institution to be a resident to
be a student
because of my own drive and with the
concept that we've happened to struggle
with now in medicine of burnout
that when we have lost our fire for what
we're doing
that that may in fact diminish our
desire
to do self-directed learning and
teachers themselves can contribute to
suppression
i can say this because i've had the
experience
getting asked a question about which a
teacher may not know
and then recognize oh my goodness i'm
changing the topic
somebody has an interest they bring a
silver platter of a learner desire
interest goal but the teacher who feels
uncomfortable at that moment
may choose to change the topic to
something the teacher knows about
so we as frail human beings as well
may contribute to the suppression of
self-directed learning
now we also found that teachers who
recognize that we may not be taking
advantage
of the power of the learner began to
capitalize on learner motivation that we
can in the midst of our teaching begin
to look to the learner
to guide us to their needs their desires
and their interests
and why is this category so important
because
when the teacher disappears it's just
the learner's
self-directed learning the learner's
recognition
of their own gaps the learner's desire
to go to resources
other people other web resources
the guy desire to even go to to go to
patients
for learning will lead to the
professional growth
beyond training
well we have dried as we've looked at
this to separate these seven categories
into distinct entities solely for the
purpose of trying to get a grasp about
on them but as you see by this
particular diagram
these categories do not live alone when
one affects the learning climate
up here in the upper left you affect
your capability of communicating
stringent educational goals
when one improves the learning climate
to where it's a safe place to address
our own limitation
we may in fact improve the learner's
desire to be evaluated by the teacher
and the learners desire to hear feedback
by the teacher
and when the learning climate is open
the learner may share
their desires their own self-directed
learning motivations
and you can walk around this particular
circle
and see each of these categories
influences
all of the others so although we've
separated them today
what is often very fun and useful
is to consider how does one category
facilitate the implementation of another
so why do we want you to have this
checklist this framework
because it will assist you with
analyzing this complex activity of
teaching
and it's like the review of systems
which all clinicians
are familiar with where we recognize we
may forget something about a patient
and going through a systematic review
can enable us to discover things that we
may have forgotten
and this seven category framework can
can provide a structured
comprehensive approach for you for your
own teaching
and it'll provide a common language so
that you may say to someone well how's
the climate
something now becoming very important as
institutions are looking at themselves
how's the climate is this session
adequately controlled
in a way to make it useful and then
again
as we've said before it may help us
recognize what we see
and what we don't see in a teaching
interaction
so as we look back on this still shot of
this
faculty member with his team
we can see that he might ask himself
gee what is the learning climate would
this student on the left-hand side of
the screen
be willing to ask a question if he
didn't know the answer
or would he feel that it would be more
appropriate
i just recently met with a group of
students where i said would you ask a
question on rounds if you didn't know
the answer
seven of the eight students in the room
said no
because i may be judged inappropriately
and i may be
judged not by interesting by being
interested in learning
but only whether or not i already know
so he may ask questions about the
learning climate
he may ask questions about is this
session controlled am i covering what i
need to cover
he may ask questions about the goals
what do i hope
for each of these learners it's an
exercise to do that for everyone
imagine this attending physician as what
does he hope the default resident will
master
as a result of this presentation
does the presentation enable him to
emphasize the things he wants to be
remembered
does it enable him in this setting to
evaluate where the learners are
and to provide feedback to those
learners and does this session enable
him
to see where the inherent drives of each
of these learners
are coming from what are their
motivations what are their interests
what are their goals
well the experience we've had in
presenting this course in
a lot greater detail over the years has
brought us to the point
where we now are working with jackie and
others
at stanford have now developed an online
course
which will become available it's an
adaptation of our
in person course that we've done for
three and a half decades
we've grounded in as much educational
theory as possible and empirical studies
of our own and our own observations in
working with teachers and learners
we've tried to do our best to have it
cover universal principles so that a
teacher who masters these concepts
can work in different cultures in
different settings with different
content
and with different learners and we've
had the wonderful experience
of working across different national
cultures
ethnic cultures and teaching cultures
from basic science features with a
certain culture
to clinical teachers with another
culture to residence in training with
their own culture
and with post-docs and their culture
we've tried to incorporate multiple
instructional methods in our facilitator
training course and in the course that
our facilitators now give
but also in our online course that there
are multiple ways that we're asking the
person who takes that course
to think about the material in a way to
help them gain what they can
from discord and the course will enable
a teacher who goes through it they have
specific suggestions
for improving their teaching practice
related to the conceptual framework that
i've covered today
and finally it has been incumbent upon
us
it has been our goal that the teacher
remains the decision maker
that we are not suggesting that we are
going to teach anybody
the way to teach there is not the way to
teach
there are multiple ways to teach so
we've tried to embody a non-prescriptive
philosophy
that enables the teacher to have a
bigger menu
to have a more complete understanding
from which they can choose
how they wish to choose their teaching
behaviors and work with their learners
so i thank you for the opportunity today
to give you the synopsis of
our course and how we're leading to the
online course and i will pass the baton
back to jackie so for our first question
kelly do you have any suggestions for
how to deliver difficult or
uncomfortable feedback to a learner
well what a wonderful question
i would highlight the three-legged stool
that i showed in the slide in the
presentation
and that is that uh in in delivering
difficult feedback
i found it very useful in preparation
for the feedback
to think about what i'm going to do to
set up a learning climate
that's going to make it a place where
that particular person receiving
feedback
wants to be can i convey to them
that i care about them enough to want to
give them that feedback
well not uncommon for me to say that as
a program director for a resident
to say it's my opportunity to tell you
about something that you may not be
aware of so to let them know the caring
that i have for them
and to let them know that whatever it is
that i'm commenting on
is very likely and i found this to be
probably the true
really 100 of the time that the issue
that they're facing
is faced by many others so the admission
of the limitations
of the learner in that setting and the
caring of the teacher
i think sets the stage it's then useful
i think to think about the communication
of goals what is it that i hope this
learner will be able to do
if they take the feedback that i'm given
that i'm giving
and use it in their career so to ask
myself
do i have a full definition of those
goals
is it knowledge is it a skill or is it
an attitude
because it's often about attitude that
is most difficult
to give feedback to a learner but to try
to define it what is the attitude what
is the behavior
that i'm hoping somebody will manifest
to display that attitude
and then finally have i done an adequate
evaluation
so i may say to a learner i only
observed you one time
but in that one time what i've seen is
this particular behavior
which i think will either help you in
the future
or in fact make it more difficult for
you
now interestingly enough i've had a
situation where a resident
might say well i'm not too worried about
this evaluation by this particular
instructor
because he actually only saw me for one
day
now i sometimes suggest it to a resident
at that point to ask
how long they think their job interview
is going to be
it's commonly less than a day
and in fact knowing how one is coming
across in even a brief encounter
can be instrumental in helping that
person decide
what it is that they wish to do with
their behaviors
in the future as malcolm gladwell said
in the book blink
so many people make instant judgments
about
certain behaviors instantaneously
and so i would hope then and i'm hoping
this will be helpful to you
to think about the preparation with the
learning climate the communication
goals and the evaluation and then
with that caring person with a
particular goal
i can then say this is what i've seen
and this is what i hope for you and then
in collaboration with that learner
because we are teaching professionals
professionals who don't simply want to
hear what somebody else has to say
but want to collaborate in the
discussion so
asking the learners what do you think
about what i've just told you about your
performance
can be very useful so i hope that is
helpful to you
it's uh i can't give you 100 guarantee
it will always work
but it will all i think it will make
things easier
and hopefully give you the courage to do
it
thank you thank you for that answer um
so the next question um and this is
i think more about how we're delivering
this content online
um and so maybe you can go a little bit
into how
um how we do the scenarios but how can
we perform
role play online in this course
well that's a difficult challenge for
even the in-person courses because
what you're highlighting and i want to
give you credit for it
is what you're highlighting is the
mastery of teaching skills
often requires practice and it's that
practice that has brought role play into
the forefront
of teaching seminars so in this case
what we're going to have to do in the
online course
is we're trying to capitalize on two
other concepts that al bandura
brought out in his work in psychology
and that is not only what he called
participant
role playing participant modeling when
you
practice the behavior yourself but also
two other kinds of modeling vicarious
modeling
in which you watch somebody else do
something and because you do have the
capability of using those
ability those particular actions you can
watch somebody and then
do it and then symbolic modeling
symbolic modeling is represented by the
conceptual
the conception of doing the behavior
it's as you practice in your mind
doing the behavior something that sports
uh sports coaches have learned for a
long time the replay
in the play of the activity before many
surgeons
talk to me about the fact that they
replay
the surgery before they go do the
surgery so in the online course
there won't be an example and an
opportunity for us to do an observed
role play
but what we're hoping to happen is that
you'll do symbolic modeling in your mind
about what you plan
vicarious modeling because we're going
to show you many different videotapes of
teachers
actually teaching reenactments of the
actual teaching that we develop
and then hopefully in some cases those
of you will
work on the course as a group and be
able to practice the behaviors
yourselves
so unfortunately there isn't an
opportunity to do the practice in there
in the online course but we will
capitalize on the two other types of
modeling
symbolic and vicarious to try to get you
on your way to doing the actual
implementation
i want to highlight for you the point
that you're making that i think you're
making in your question
is that the mastery of a new behavior
requires practice
so i would encourage you all those of
you who take our full course or regular
course whatever the course is
that as much as possible identify the
time when you wish to practice
the behavior your plan you're planning
to use
wonderful question great answer thanks
kelly
the next question is as a corollary when
giving difficult
feedback how might your recommendations
change
if a new or junior faculty is providing
challenging feedback to a learner to
make sure the feedback lands
successfully
and the newer junior faculty remains
protected
did i hear the newer junior faculty
remains protected
is that what i heard yes well
two very very challenging issues first i
would try to
capitalize for new or junior faculty
on the fact that at that particular
stage a stage which i passed some time
ago
at that particular stage you have the
opportunity to be what the educators
will call
a near peer a near pier
that if you are new as a faculty member
you probably have a greater grasp of
what the resident or students or interns
are going through
than somebody who has been away from the
training program for a long time
so first i would encourage you to
recognize that you have a capability
that people who have been well beyond
that
new faculty member definition no longer
have
so you can say in your introduction to
your feedback
i have recently been where you are
and the credibility and the utility of
being there recently
can have merit now you brought up
another point and that is that you want
to protect the teacher now why do we
have to talk about this
is a sad point this is a sad
point the teachers now
are fearful of the evaluation of them
by a learner because of how that may
affect their career
so we now have saying that teachers
have just been like learners who are
fearful about how they're being
evaluated
that teachers may avoid very effective
educational behavior
for fear that the learner will not like
it
and therefore will reject it so my
encouragement at this point would be to
make sure as much as you possibly can
that the reason for your feedback is
sincere
and honest and for the benefit of the
learner
if they can recognize that the reason
you're giving your feedback
is for their benefit and i just had the
wonderful opportunity
to work with a young faculty member in
this regard
the explanation to the learner as to the
rationale for the teacher's behavior
becomes very important so i would
encourage you to do those
those several things
explain your and your peer explain your
observations as clearly as possible
and explain that the rationale for you
doing this
is for the benefit of that person and
all the patients that they will touch
afterwards and all the colleagues that
they'll interact with afterwards
now i cannot give you 100 guarantee
that it's going to become a simple
process it never was a simple process
for me
but i think it can be a more effective
process if you add those particular
adjunct behaviors thank you so much
wonderful questions
perfect thank you kelly um the next
question is i have students that reach a
point where i know they will not pass my
course
so how do you communicate this to them
and help them figure out what their
options are
finish the course and try again or drop
right then in there but also support
them
and help them find another way to
achieve their goal
gee what a wonderful another wonderful
deep question
because you're talking about career
choice in some cases
here how can i let somebody know
that out of my course and my teaching
we've discovered something about them
that might guide them to a different
area
well it might guide them that they may
not be approaching the course or they
may be so fearful that they're not
really
being able to put forth their best
efforts so first one would want to check
that in fact somebody is not capable
capable
of mastering the material and in fact
i've had that experience where somebody
might change fields
because of capability and i'm a believer
in capability
i think i'm a far less good surgeon than
i am as an internist
i believe in capability and so it may
well be
that you are doing something very useful
for your learner
to say to them here's what i've
discovered here's what i've seen
here's what i hope and here's where i'm
concerned
now you and i are in a collaborative
model now
the teacher and the learner you and i
are working
together on your career so we have to
decide
is this the right place for you and can
you master the skills necessary
or is this not the right place for you
i've always felt that we have to be open
that many people are choosing their
careers on the basis of an inadequate
amount of knowledge
and that the thought about changing the
career should not be something that is
actually totally avoided at all
one of my poster children in my
experience had been one of my residents
who told me because he was not
performing well that he really did not
want to be a practicing clinician
and so we enabled him to leave that
field
and then he became a very famous very
famous and very successful
world health organization expert so
i think the fear of people changing
fields obviously they put a lot of time
into medicine
but we want them to be happy for their
careers and not being
doing something where they're always on
the edge of being
not successful thank you god these are
wonderful questions
thanks kelly we might have time for one
or two more
we have actually a lot of great
questions here um so
the next question is um and this is a
great one also
how do you know that as a teacher you
are correct when you give
negative feedback and not just prejudice
or at the end of the day it is just your
subjective
opinion
new issues all the biases that we're now
learning that many of us have had as
we're making our evaluation and giving
feedback
how do we know i think the best thing we
can do is to tell people that this is
what we see
where the the um
insistence on ourselves that when we're
giving feedback we're
talking about the observations that
we've made
so that there's not an argument about
what we
interpret but rather a discussion of
what we observe
so that what we know we can be certain
of is this is what we saw
what we can't be certain of what was the
intent and what it may mean to others
so i think if we can say that openly i'm
going to tell you what i saw i'm going
to tell you
what how i interpret it i can tell you
that it may be interpreted in the same
way that i
am by others and if we think that the
learners
changing of that behavior would be
useful for them in their careers then i
think we're giving we're offering them
what others may feel about their
performance that they don't know
you know there's many famous lines about
seeing others as others people see us
you know that we don't see ourselves as
other people see us
and yet in medicine in in all many
fields
in all the fields knowing how other
people see us
is going to be crucial to our success so
once again there's an
honesty coming here that we're that i'm
thinking can be very useful
and something that i think the field of
medicine can be
very proud about and start doing more
than we're doing now
an honesty about our commitment to our
learners
and an honesty about our observations of
our learners
great thank you so much i guess we have
one time for one more jackie
we can throw in one more um let's see
here
so the next question is can you give
some suggestions
um on how to improve or establish a good
learning climate
well there are many and this is going to
be making me want to invite you to take
the online course because
in the online course we're going to give
about 40 different you know at least
i'm doing the math here about 20
different suggestions
for improving the learning climate
suggesting
suggestions dealing with the four
components that we highlight for the
learning climate
we suggest that the learning climate is
made up of four areas
the area of stimulation an area where
the teacher
can let learners know about how much he
or she cares about their learning
the area of involvement an area where
the teachers say to the learners
i really want you however hesitant or
reticent
or quiet you are to be a participant in
this
exercise the area of admission of
limitations
in which we can acknowledge the
limitations that others have
and point out the utility of those to
further learning
and finally the area of you and i
admitting all the limitations that we
face the area
of respect for limitation that we can
acknowledge where people are but we can
also highlight for them
that it is fine and it is a useful thing
to talk about the limitations of
ourselves
the limitations of others the
limitations of the place we teach
the limitations of the content that we
teach all of those i would think can be
suggestions
that might enable you to make a more
positive learning climate
we highlighted in this morning's session
only one
the admission of one's own limitation
and that's powerful
because a teacher who says to a learner
i have a limitation and i've made a
mistake in this area
and i don't want you to make the same
mistake
the idea that is professional the
mistake should not be made multiple
times
it should be made once and passed on to
others
so that opening up the mistakes as
stepping stones to learning
can be another way to help the learning
climate
so there's a few suggestions and like i
say
it makes me want to either have you take
the online
course or in the live course however we
can get you more information
would be better thank you so much for
all of these questions
great thanks kelly all right well
i think time flew by it's about time to
wrap up the webinar
um again if you'd like to learn more
from kelly and georgette we encourage
you to join
our mastering medical teaching course
you'll have
over 12 hours of content to learn from
them
and other guest speakers as well
and access to videos and exercises to
sharpen your skills
and again as kelly said learn more about
providing a positive learning climate
and once again thank you for joining us
today we hope you all have a great week
and we hope to see you again
in one of our next sessions thank you
kelly
thank you
you